[Musique]
andré quartiers dits poupou habite à
marseille dans une de ces grandes
avenues bourgeoise qui ont été percés au
19e siècle et qui inexorablement avait
rejeté le panier à l'écart ou coups par
ses amis peintres a découvert le panier
il en est devenu le chroniqueur le guide
bénévole
scénario par le verset lanka qu'à
marseille c'est un bateau qui vient à sa
règle en disque à marseille
c'est la ville de flers
[Musique]
c'est un an maintenant qu'elle se liait
les servir
et ali massa toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elie baup chaud
et maintenant
quelque chose
aviez vous savez bien papier doré daily
nation et seulement ça marche bien et la
scion iq avec thalassa c'est très bien
c'est donc rien aurait vendu le poisson
oui je donnais le poisson lapointe
je me rappelle comme ici lorsque
j'arrivais le noter je pensais à crier
et que les remarques euros à tous les
couples n'est pas violer et qu'elle est
même façon il était toujours prêt à il
était impeccable
les oiseaux
non je n'aime pas ce voyage je suis
d'ailleurs je suis né l'orge habitants
ma mère y aurait 3 a longtemps la santé
18 en amérique et la victory lane
moi je souhaite que deux amis à 62,2 ac
le toujours très contente c'est pas
évident avant la pause un quartier à
marseille où les enfants je n'ai pas mon
mari
[Musique]
ce colloque
addition à tout va c'est à neutre à flat
[Musique]
pas encore à jour 4.2 et à mieux aborder
le bond de la savait que la chance je
t'ai rencontré toi tu as fait connaître
le panier oui on dirait que ça vaut ça
vous apporte une gaieté et dire qu'il a
si mauvaise réputation même auprès des
marseillais
c'est une fausse opinion parce que moi
je suis une amitié
très très chaude quoi tenait le garde
dans ces immeubles art au paradis ou
badauds ceux qui habitent au rez de
chaussée connaissent même passés du
simple ici à 200-300 mètres de distance
on disait bonjour à régler ça ce qui est
assez qu'il ya un climat social très
très chaleureux très fraternelle moi je
suis trop bien je me sens bien j'ai une
source d'inspiration constante
puis les jeunes vous adoptent tels que
vous ayez trouvé ça va ça il y en ad
numéro un ici on n'est pas l'artiste
carrément on est l'être humain est un
artiste à puce et c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est
oh pas nier la réalité journalière des
enfants de la rue protège l'artiste de
la tentation des coteries et des modes
c'est le cas pour les peintres ferrara
angélini cornilleau est ici audry bono
c'est le cas du sculpteur yves ange
bourdin c'est ce qui anime puis la gym
et apprenez un pour tourner le saint
quentin pour pouvoir dessiner comme les
amis fans oui mais ça va les revoir dans
l'enfant est rédigé en est un ça veut
dire que tu as la propreté impossible il
faudrait pouvoir sculpté et peint comme
c'est pour ça qu'il faut se mettre
toujours dans son coin et peine d'être
en qui les difficultés tranquille subir
surtout aucune influence surtout
qu'interdit pas du génial parce que
finalement il en est un signe sedum
résigne pas le chill oui d'accord ça
c'est là je fais moi pour moi elle en a
les qualités
comment veux tu en as toi il fallait le
moins possible dans les revues même
possible les 10% hongrie
la place principale du panier s'appelle
la place des moulins jadis il y en avait
sept et les marseillais se vengeait des
assauts de leurs mistral en asservissant
son énergie pour moudre leur blé
aujourd'hui le vent c'est encore à
sécher le linge
aujourd'hui à du vin et beaucoup de
verts aujourd'hui c'est dommage parce
que les billets sera louis c'est dommage
je connais bien il ya longtemps que vous
êtes un quartier oui j'y suis né dans le
quartier de 77 ans intestins et dans la
maison j'habite j'ai fait un enfant j'ai
perdu mon mari à 55,15 nécessaire jarre
mon mari j'aimais le popul
et il habitait le panu a lui aussi vis à
vis des muette à loin de chez moi
la bouche est l'un des mariés un des 100
et j'ai eu un petit 22 le 2e 23 le
troisième un bento 6e et 4e et ci dessus
et ça a continué jeu dans des halos
plein de pubs bourdonnières et puis je
me laisse aller au coin pendant la
guerre ce quartier était mal fréquenté
mais vous savez les voyous étaient pas
mauvais non j'étais pas mauvais les
voyous qui s'entretuaient un peu mais
nous le faisait part du mal non il n'ya
plus des gens comme avant c'est calme
maintenant c'est très calme ici c'est
des ouvriers c2c s'est plaint d'ouvriers
s'étaient l'ouvrier qui a beaucoup
d'arabes
mais son p et noir sans tranquille oui
ce quartier j'ai toujours aimé un oui
j'ai toujours habité la rue du refuge
hugo 5 toujours paniers dont la
là je pourrai 7 5 jeudi
voilà ma bonne dame
elle est très jolie voilà tu aimerais
bien moi les très belles
c'est bien simple et fort nous
l'assurent jamais ce ne sera la butte
montmartre
si grande est la sagesse des habitants
du panier espérons que notre
indiscrétions ne va pas leur compliquer
la tâche mais ne fallait-il pas même à
titre d'exemple cité le panier car ils
sont rares les endroits où l'art et dans
la vie et la vie dans la
[Musique]